Hello dad
D - Would you like me to sit?
H - You could sit right there.
H - Good morning, John
We were having dinner the other night
H -With this our dad and I found out about a habit of yours when you are what how old?
D - wasn't it wasn't a habit
I could stop anytime. I wanted to. It was after-school ritual when I was eight or nine or ten
You know a long day, on the school bus, come in to the
Kitchen, get out some white bread, Wonder Bread, and put two or three teaspoons of sugar on the bread and then just eat it.
D - Crunch crunch.
H - That's been a long time since since you've done that
D - Well, yeah
H - Do you think that it's gonna be familiar if we do this again?
Oh, I can feel the crunch right now, but I don't know that it's gonna be a good thing
Well, I really want to try it. We've got some classic white bread. This is pretty doughy gooey stuff
So make make it for me Dad. Other people do this? Where you just like take the sugar and put it in your mouth?
D - As a kid?
D - You do it cuz you can.
H - No cuz kids now have actual candy.
D - Don't know how I did this
D - I'm sure I didn't just like tap my fingers.
H - So that's one spoonful.
D - I did it alone, okay? My mother wasn't there, my brothers weren't there.
H - Did you think you were getting away with something?
D - No, I
D- It was a snack. I don't remember drinking a lot of sodas and they're like, you know, there's like a third sugar
H - It's soda bread. That's different. Then you sort of balanced the sugar on the bread
Carefully.
D - It's not nearly as thick as what I used to eat.
H - Well then
Well then
Well then we gotta be authentic.
We should put more of it!
H -Oh, wow, that's a lot. You gotta shake it so it gets in the nooks and crannies.
D -Yeah, I'm gonna do this.
H - Yeah, three two one
mmm
D - There's that crunch ...
H - Is there?
D - I remember it!
D -That's not bad at I thought it would be
H - That's not bad at all.
D - Oh my god do I have to eat the whole thing?
H - do you want to eat the whole thing?
D - I could.
H - You already ate a lot of it!
H -Look at how much he's already eaten. "Do I have to eat the whole thing" and he's like 90% done?!
Okay, okay, let's put it down
I also have another segment of the video a bunch of people have said nice things about my book
H - But I don't feel right reading them out loud my self. I cut them out and put them on little pieces of ...
D - Yeah
H - Paper board for my dad to read.
D - Led by an earnestly flawed bisexual heroine with direction and commitment issues. Sounds like
All the young people I know
coupled with an abundant generosity of spirit
this read is timely and sorely needed. Highly recommended funny thrilling an
Absolute blast to read I knew Hank would be good at this but I didn't know he would be this good on his first try
I think I would be less good on my second try if that's any consolation
This is the book. My team self would have loved and my adult self immediately obsessed over. By turns, joyful devastating personal
Zeitgeisty modern classic fast-paced and thoughtful an absolutely remarkable thing blew me away. I read it
D - I read it, it's a good book.
That's a good blurb. I'll put that in there
I wanted to eat a bunch of sugar bread to excuse me spending this entire video promoting things
We're also going on tour. All the new tour information is up now and Hank green dot com
They're apparently selling pretty fast already. And then lastly PodCon is happening again. You were at pod con.
D- It was a good con.
D - I was, gonna come again
H - What was your review of PodCon? I went to pod con. It was a good pod con.
D - It was a good con. Pod Con was great!
D - Mama green doesn't like to go to big conference.
H - Well, this is mrs
Green catherine is coming too.
D - yeah
H - so all the mrs
Green's will be there
and if you want to learn more about pod con you can go to pod dot com, our crowdfunding campaign is live now and we
Need people to sign up
So if you're not gonna see me on tour
Maybe you could see me at pod calm which will be January 19th
and 20th in Seattle Washington. Have even transported back to your youth
D - I was man, I am. With that crunch. H - You know, I was making so much fun of you, but this isn't bad
D - This is like a freakin Danish.
H - Yeah, it makes it makes you think maybe I should eat fewer danishes
D - Exactly.
H - John.. I'll see you on Tuesday
I don't know how that's gonna edit together, but not into four minutes!
D - My mentor said to me the more you cut the better it gets.
H - it gets true. That's the whole thesis of vlogbrothers. Did you finish yours?
D- Hell yes